よろしくお願いします
いや あの 今年の最後のテーマとして
まあ決断というテーマでございます
それほど難しいことではないんだからね
まあほんの少々何か何かを
ポイントを申し上げて
それから皆様方は まあ自分自分がぶつかった問題とかね
決断できなかったこととか
あるいは今もなかなか決断できなくて悩んでいることとか
そういうものを具体的に言うと
その場合はどのように仏教的に知恵を働かせますかということは具体的に説明できますので
まあ単なる基本的なやり方
基本的なところだけ まあ一部としてお話しさせていただきます
それからこのテーマはね
まあ一応リピートしていると思いますけど
あの なんかこの前も何回かお話をした覚えがあるんです
ですから この どうすればいいんでしょうかね
あまりリピートになると
まああまり私は真剣にいろいろ情報を調べようとはしないんです
で 私たちの生き方っていうのは
まあどんな生命であろうと
まあ生き方っていうのは
生きているということは
ずっと限りなく判断して判断して続けていかなくちゃいけないことなんです
だから 何かを判断するという能力っていうのは
生きているものに 人間だけではなくて
生きているものに 誰にでも必ず必要なものなんです
もし判断能力がなくなったら
それでその生き物には生きていられなくなります
ですから もう答えが簡単です
あまり亡くなった方一人もいませんね
ですから みんな判断能力があるということなんです
で 判断能力なくなっちゃうと
もう生きていられないんです
そう言うと 何かじゃあ人が事故
事故で死んじゃうとかね
病気になって死ぬとか
あるいは判断能力がなくなったことかどうか
まあそれはもう判断と関係なく
まあ人は死にますから
あの まあそれとは関係ありません
一応生きているということは判断し続けていくことなんです
そういうことだから 別にまあ判断
どのように判断すればすればよろしいかということは
特別に勉強する必要はないんです
本能としてあるはずなんです
それから この判断ミスということは
あの よく人間に見えることなんですね
判断ミスしたっていうことは
よく人間にあることです
それは人間だけではなくてね
まあ動物にも見えないわけじゃないんです
この部屋に例えば鳥でも虫でもなんとか入っちゃったところで
まあ逃げようとするでしょ
ガラスにぶつかっちゃうんですね
逃げられないんで そこをどこかで窓を開けてあげたっても
そちらに行かない とにかくガラスの方に行っちゃう
あれ 判断ミスでしょ わかりやすく言えば
その虫の 正しく判断すれば空いてるところから行くんだけどね
でも虫はこう判断するんですね
ものすごくでっかく光を見る所は外であって
逃げようではないか そこら辺でほんのちょっと窓を開けてあったっても
あまり見ようとしない
自分が先に見た空をずっとしがみついて
そこに好かれて なんていうのは好いてるんですね
だからもう試しに まあ皆様虫が入ったらなんか恐ろしい
もうライオンが入ったような感じでびっくりするんだから
どうしようもないんだけど
まあ普通に虫なんか部屋に入ったら
まあ窓を開けてみてください
行かないんですね 自分見た場所からずっと空を睨んでるんです
そこで出してあげようと思っても
なんか変なことするんではないかと思って
また逃げてまた窓に止まっちゃうということはあります
ですから 動物の世界でも判断ミスということは見えるんですね
そういう単純な例で考えちゃうと
なんで人間が判断ミスするかと同じことなんです
我々は虫より周り見えるんだから
まあ虫のことはわかりますけどね
で 虫は自分のことはわからないんですね
自分が先に見た空は それは外
なんか窓を開けたっても
そちらにカーテンとかいろいろあるでしょう
だから虫から見れば これやばいところなんですね
それは中だから そちらには行かない
それで人間も判断ミスなんかしたならば
同じ働きなんです 同じ機能
全く同じ機能 その判断ミスをした人にとってはそれしか見えないんです
で 正しい判断の方向は
まあちょっとやばいではないかというふうな感じがするんです
そういうことだから 判断ミスする人にとっては
もうなかなかそれ直すということを正すということはできない
そこで人の間違いを直そうと思ったら
我々は虫を捕まって外へ出すような感じで
強引に もう嫌で嫌で 本人が本人が嫌でも攻撃するにも関わらず
強引にやらせなくちゃいけないことになっちゃうんですね
正しいことを その経験は皆様にあると思います
ご自分に対しても 自分が何かやりたがっていると
他の人々はすごい強引に
無理やりに 自分の意思にものすごく反対させてして
違うことに違うことをさせようとしたことと
自分たちが自分の子供たちへらいらんのと人に強引にいろんなこと
それじゃなくて それ良くないんですよと
やめなさいよと 強引にやめさせたこととかね
あるでしょう それはもう判断の世界なんですね
だから虫と同じなんです
だから生命の真理っていうのは
この 私がすごくそうやってものすごい普遍的に見てほしいんです
私の立場から言えば 特別に人間だけ偉く扱って偉いと
見ると問題は見えなくなるんです
それだけで判断ミスなんですね
だから人類の考え方っていうのは
すべて人間中心に ここに我
私がいるんだという で
自分中心にすべての世界を考えて理解しようとする
それであの小さな虫と何が違うんですか？何も違うところはない
そこであまり真理が見えなくなるんですね
自分に見える世界だけ正しくて
他人に見える世界は間違っている
自分たちが考えるものは正しくて
他人が他の立場で考えることは間違っていると思ったりする
そういうことで頭がすごく狭くなるんですね
そういうことだから 生命という一般的な
ものすごい普遍的な土台から考えた方が
まあより大きい視野で物事を見えるんです
そうすると この毎日の判断の問題も
まあより正しく まあ使うことはできるだろうと思います
だから私が今困ってますけど
何に困ってるかというと
まあどこまで喋ってどこまででストップするかっていう問題なんですね
どういうことかというと
判断っていうのは教えてあげなくても
生命が判断しなきゃ生きていられないし
だからまあそれなりに生きているということは
ちゃんと判断しているということ
短命になったということを判断は間違ったということ
あまりうまく生きていられないこの世の中でというならば
まあそれはいろんなところで判断は間違っているということですから
まあそれなりに問題なく生きているならば
まあ適当な適切な判断能力はあるということになるんです
ですから それは本来人間のでではなくて
生命の本能というものの一部なんですね
この本能というもの 何でしょうかね
その言葉は仏教の言葉じゃないんです
仏教には本能という言葉はないんですけどね
日本語だからないわけじゃなくて
パーリ語でもないんです
まあ英語だったらインスタインクトですか
という言葉がありますね
それを本能と日本がつけているんですね
それはあんまり使ってない
ないんですね なんで西洋でこのインスタインクトという
あるいは本能という言葉が作ったかというと
人間の思考で 世の中のことを観察しちゃうと
どうもわからないとこが出てくるんですね
なんかわからないと 人間の目で見ればわからないかもしれませんだけどね
虫の目で見れば 窓が開いて開いてるってことも見えない
わからないんだからね
同じことなんです  特にこの動物の世界を観察すると
なんかどうもわからないところがいっぱいあるんですね
ある魚の一種類がありまして
そのオスが 全部このちっちゃな
このまあ 孵化というんですか？卵
ん？孵化した小さな子供たちを全部自分の口の中に入れちゃうんですね
全部口の中に入れて 口の中でまあ守ってるんです
だから生まれたばっかしの魚
ほんの小さいんですけど
周りの世界何も見えないのに
なんのことなく平気でオスの口の中に入っちゃうんですね
で オスもあれ飲み込んじゃったらどうしますかね
あれ 不思議でしょ？全然 1匹も飲み込まない
ちゃんと口の中で水を交換しながらもう
守るんですね そこで周りは大丈夫かなと見えたところで口を開けてあげる
それで外へ出て そこら辺いるんだけど
また危険だなと思ったら
パクパクパク全部また口の中に入れちゃうんですね
だからマニュアルないんですね
口の中に正しく子供の育ち方
歯で怪我しないようにどのようにすればよろしいかと
飲み込めないように どのように気を付ければよろしいかと
全然マニュアル テキストないんです
よく頑張ってやっちゃうでしょうね
ペンギンなんかの卵のあれ
温め方もなんかすごい不思議でしょうし
である時間ずっとオスがもう卵を温めていて
それでメスが外へ出て行って
長い旅をして餌を食べて食べて食べて
で来る で その間ずっともうオスの方が何も食べないで
ずっと卵を温めるだけで
１日２日のところじゃないんです
それでメスがもう食べて食べてきたら
もう で すぐ瞬時に卵を渡してあげるんですね
メスに なんかカメラでしか見たことないんだけど
カメラでも撮れないぐらい早く渡してあげる
なぜかというと これもう零度以下
もう 20度ね とか すごい寒いところだから
だから外の寒さが何も触れないうちにさっと渡してあげて
それでオスがまた長い旅をするんですよ
餌を探しに だから ああいう風な
なんでそういうことをできるんでしょうかね
そこでの１匹 まあもうまた種類の鳥がいて
ものすごい芸術作品のように巣を作るんですね
きれいにこの繊維持ってきて編むんです
編み物のように 編んで編んで編んで編んで作って
제가見た鳥の巣っていうのは
この枝の先にぶら下がっていて
真ん中卵を置くところで
入り口は下なんですね
下からずっと中に入らなくちゃならない
だからヘビなんかはどう頑張っても入れません
これ 枝の先まで行って
また下へ行って また上に行かなくちゃ
そこまではこのカーブはできません
ヘビに どう頑張っても入れません
そこで出口 入り口が 玄関は下だから卵を落っこっちゃうでしょうね
下に そう起こらないように上ちゃんと部屋を作って
それだけ不思議じゃないんです
あれ ものすごいすばらしく編むんです
細い繊維で 不思議なのは中に光がついてるんです
あのあれ あのホタル捕まってきて壁に貼っちゃうんです
ですから これ不思議でしょ？でも別にその鳥の学校もないんですよ
お嫁さん修業ということで
メスに まあこれからあんた巣を作る
まあ両方二人で作りますけどね
まあその場合のこういう風に編みますよとかね
ないんですね なんでそういうことできるかということは
もう人間にはわからないんですね
だからそういうものを研究した人間たちが人間の目で見ているんだから
人間偉いんだから この偉い人間から見ればわからない
でも 次の鳥も次の鳥も次の動物
次々から生まれ みんなきちんとこのパターンだけは大事に守ってやるんですね
それにまあわかりやすく本能だと言って胸を張るんですね
本能だって言ったって説明できてないでしょうに
あれ 科学者は言うべき言葉じゃないんです
それはまあ本能ですよ
だからそれ全然説明になりません
そういうわけだから 仏教で本能という言葉がないのは当たり前なんです
そんなわけもわからない言葉でごまかすということはないんです
でも 世の中で我々普通に使ってるんだから
まあなんか分かったような気がしますね
本能ですよと言ったら
それはまあインチキ科学の世界でおかげでもうなっていること
人を騙すのはいとも簡単
何か言葉を言っちゃえばね
あ そうですか はい わかりました
そういうことだから この本能ということはあんまりありがたい言葉ではありませんだけど
一つ言えるなのは 人間だけではなくて
どんな生命にもちゃんと判断能力はあるということ
あることはあるんだけど
判断ミスということはもあります
だからその判断ミスを犯したところでトラブルが起きちゃうんですね
それは動物の世界でもよく見える
あの前に出した例の虫の話ではなくて
野生の中で生活している動物もたまたま判断ミスをして大変なことになるということはありますね
今はね 自然も汚染されているんだから
あの餌を食べる時はもうもうなんとか色で決めて食べたりする
で そうすると この海に出しているいろんなゴミとかね
プラスチックのものとか
時々このライターとかね
それまで飲み込んじゃったりして
針金やらこの魚釣る時使うなんとかありますね
そういうものとかね で
飲み込んだりして それでもう死んでしまっちゃうでしょうね
それもはっきり言えば
もう判断ミスなんですね
その動物の だからまあ
そういうことで早く死んでしまっちゃう
殲滅状態にもなってしまっちゃうしね
で 同じく人間もいろんなことで判断ミスを犯してしまっちゃうんですね
それはこんなもう講義聞いたんだからといって
判断ミスをしない人生やるぞと思ったってもね
無理だと思いますけど
ですから このもう一回
あの前の例に戻ってよく考えてください
我々はこの窓から出ようとしている虫に対して腹が立つべきか
怒るべきですか？と バカやと言うべきですか？と
カーテンのところまでを開けているのにね
そちらから出ていけばいいでしょうに
そこで虫がもうきれいに閉めているところからとにかく出て行こう
出て行こうと 大きな建物なんか時々このね
作り作っているばっかしだったら
中に何も家具を入れてないでしょ
そうすると こちらの窓から向こうの窓見えるし
それで鳥がぶつかって死んじゃうこともあるでしょうしね
ですから鳥バカですかね
その場合は そこら辺 ちょっとこの人間中心ではなくて
自分が虫になって考えてほしいんです
そうすると もうなんとなくわかるでしょ
なんかその虫にとっては
まあどうしようもない状態なんです
他の道っていうのは発見できるはずもないんです
自分の能力の世界で それしか外ではないんだから
先に見えた大きな大きく映った世界は空であって
それぐるぐるぐるあっちこっちから曲がって曲がって曲がっていったところで
外に出られるんだというところまでは頭の中にないでしょう
それ わからないことをどうやっても理解しなさいと言っても
それは理解できるわけじゃないんです
ですから このこれ大変な問題なんです
だから人間にしたっても
まあ人間だから判断ミスを何もしない
ちゃんとして決断できる生き方したいなと思っても
その点で考えると これ大変なことでもあります
だから判断ミスを犯した人にとっては
それ自分の能力のギリギリの範囲なんです
それ以上できないんです
小学生1年生で もう数学的ないろいろ足し算引き算とかやってますけど
その子供に例えば高校生の問題出してあげると言ったって
これどう考えたって無理でしょうね
じゃあ頑張って教えてあげようと
無理でしょ だから能力はそれ以上ないんだからね
で そういう風に理解していただきたいんですね
この判断する世界のこと
判断ミスをした人が悪魔扱いするんじゃなくて
敵扱いするんじゃなくてね
ああ やっぱりそうかと
そういう風にもっと大きな心でね
見るべきなんです それでかなり人生は楽になるんですよ
なんでそういうことを言うんですかというと
我々はいろんな人に対して
あの人間違った この人間違った
この人間違ったとかね
あの人正しくないとか
この人も悪いとかね ずっと言ってるでしょうに
家族の中でもそうでしょ
もう喧嘩するんですね
相手が間違ってるんだと
親が間違ってる お姑さんが間違ってると
舅さんが間違ってる お嫁が間違ってる
子供が間違ってる  すごく威張って相手のことだけ堂々と言うこと
で それさえも間違っていると
姑さんが自分をいじめているんだと
だから悪いんだという自分も悪いということなんですね
それは世の中のこと 生命のことを理解していない
自分の小さな世界しか見てない
自分がいる世界すべてだと
だから小さな殻を作って
全部閉じて これすべて世界ですよと
それ以外以外何もあるはずがないんだと
もう決めつけちゃって
それも判断だと それも間違い判断でありますね
そういうわけだから まず先にこの虫の話出しちゃったんです
だから まあ怒るかもしれませんだけど
我々偉大なる人間が虫と同じレベルで見ているんだと
まあ怒ったっても まあもう何かする前に私は帰りますからね
大丈夫ですけど で それでもやっぱり同じレベルに置いておくんです
餌だと間違って何かとんでもないものを食べてしまうしまう動物いるし
それで人間から見れば
その動物はかわいそうだと
なんとか助けてあげなくちゃいけないんだと思うでしょうに
学校を作っては 例えば海の中で危険なものはいっぱいあって
その中で生活している動物たち
鳥たちとかね あんなものは食べちゃって
もういっぱい死んでるの
テレビで最近見ましたからね
そうすると誰も思わないんです
その鳥たちをみんなまとめて訓練してあげようと
正しい餌の取り方と食べてはいけないものの見分け方とかね
そんなことは思わない
逆に思うのは 海を汚すなと
なぜならば その動物たちはかわいそうなんですね
そういう判断しかできませんだから
優しく守ってあげなくちゃいけないんです
それはじゃあ人間に与えてみたらどうですかね
もし誰かが自分に対して判断ミスを犯したならば
どんな態度を取るべきですかね
物事を見える人だったら
理解できる人だったら
だったら あの自然の動物を守ろうと頑張っている人々と同じ態度を取るべきでしょう
判断間違った人をやっぱりもっと大きい心で
もっと優しい心で見守ってあげなくちゃいけない
それはまあ 人間が偉いんだったら
そういう道を取るべきなんです
でも その道は取れないでしょうに
動物に対しても 一部の動物に対してその
道を選ぶんだけど また他の動物に対してすごい恐ろしく過ごしちゃうし
ですから まあこの周庭というのは
私は他の言葉知らないんだから言うだけのことなんですけど
周庭さんがお嫁さんをいじめているんだというならば
やっぱりお嫁さんの仕事っていうのは
周庭さんのことはより広い心で
より優しい心で見守ってあげることなんですね
その大きい心が生まれれば
人間の判断のミスの問題はまあ結構解決すると思います
いろんなところでそれを解決します
だから問題はこの心の狭いということと
自分中心にしか物事を考えられないということ
だから人間がこの虫の人生を卒業した方がいいんです
判断ミスは誰でもする
誰でも犯してしまっちゃう
でも本人は責めるべきではありません
本人にはそれ精いっぱいの判断なんです
なんでそう言うんでしょうか
この判断というのは本能だからなんです
と言ったら何の意味もないんですけど
もう判断っていうのはもうみんなずっとやってるんだからなんです
判断する場合は 私がわざと間違い判断するんだということは論理的には成り立たないでしょう
論理的に成り立たないんです
だから判断する人が最良の判断をしているんです
選択する人は一番いい選択をしているんです
それでその選択 その判断が間違っていると他の人に見えたところで
あの人を責めることはできないんです
だから心を大きくしましょうと
まあまあ 軽々例を出しちゃうと
誰もわかりやすいんですよ
こちら 腐ってるリンゴ 1つと
まあすごい元気に元気なみずみずしい
まあ取って 2日 3日も経ってないリンゴ 1個置いておいて
じゃあ一つどうぞ食べてちょうだいと言ったら
あっ あの腐っていて まあ味もないものを選びますか？選べないでしょ
判断っていうのはそういうことで
一番正しい判断はその時するんです
それで私がずるい人だから
この新しいリンゴの中に何かすごいもう苦い何か入れておく
腐りかけてるリンゴはすごく美味しくしておくと
それでも相手が新しいものを選ぶ
選んだところで失敗しましたと分かったっても
その人を責めるべきではありません
そういうことだから 子供は学校に行きません
行かないんだと判断しちゃうと
その子供は自分にとっては一番いい判断をしているんです
私は間違っている判断
腐っているリンゴを選びますよということはしません
皆様方 買い物に行ったところで
店で同じものがたくさん並んでいるところで
何か選んだとする なんであんたこれ選んだんですか？いえ
これちょっと破れていたんだから選んだと言いますか
冊子にしたっても 冊子やと一冊だけ見本として置いておく
それみんな見て見て見て見て見て
まあほとんどまあ汚れている
自分が同じ冊子を買いたい場合は
見本だけ持ってきて あ
これ買います 何でしょうか
それ買うんですか？これ汚れているんだから買わないでしょう
その場合は誰も触ってない
開けてない冊子を下から引っ張るでしょうに
だからよく聞いた話なんですけど
奥様方は牛乳なんか買う場合は
一番後ろにある牛乳を取るんだそうです
それを知っている店の人々は
全部古い牛乳は後ろに入れてあると
もう卵の場合もそうみたいですね
おばあ様方は後ろのものを取り前のを怒っちゃうんですよ
あれで見たこともないわけでもないんだけどね
それで平気でそれを置いて帰っちゃうんです
だからその場合も 並んでる牛乳の一番後ろの1本取った人が
自分が一番正しい判断をしているんです
日にち見たら もっと新しいものが一番前にあるかもしれませんけど
そういうことだから 我々は決断する
決断する 自分が決めることが自分にとっては一番最高なこと
正しいことをやっているんです
だからその人を責めるべきではないんです
なんとか違う立場からやっぱり助けてあげなくちゃいけないんです
例えばあの卵 牛乳パックをまあ後ろから取るんじゃなくて
日にち見ればよろしいですよと
日にちを見て選ぶんだと
で 教えてあげればいいでしょうに
まあ大体まあそういうぐらいのことなんで
一応今日理解してほしいのは
この決断の問題っていうのはどんな生命でもやっていることであることを
それからどんな生命も大量の決断していること
でももうちょっと大きい智慧で見ると
それは間違っている可能性もあるということ
間違ったんだからで その人を責めることは
それはけしからんなことであると
それで我々の立ってどうすればよろしいかというと
この海が汚染されて もう海に生活している鳥たちが死んでると
海を汚染するなと 人間がこんなことやってるんだからかわいそうに死んでるんだ
だからまあ鳥に学校を開くんではなくて
人間がやっぱり海を汚さないようにした方がよろしいというふうな判断と同じく
我々はまあよりより良い社会のために努力するべきなんですね
だからそれは一緒で 私はこの3番目の選択という言葉を使っているし
あの まあ決断の話になると
どうしても中道のね 話になりますから
仏教専門用語から言えると
仏教の中道っていうのはこの3番目の選択ということなんですね
じゃあこれからの言ったところから何かわかることあると思います
なんで判断ミスしますかと
それは理解の問題でしょ
自分が理解している範囲の問題で
より大きな範囲で より大きな視野というか
アングルで理解すると
もっといい判断できるだろうと
だから我々にどれぐらい幅広く世の中が見えるかという問題なんですね
で それに仏教を答えているのは
これ生命の問題だから
人間中心に考えてはいけませんと
生命として見てみましょうと
そうするとすごい大きな世界が見えてきます
そうすると ほぼ間違わないように生きていられます
完璧に間違わないように生きてますということは
まあまあやめた方がいいんです
気持ち悪いんですよ 完璧な人間っていうのは
いろいろまあ失敗したり
まあアホなことしたりする人間っていうのは
まあもう結構可愛いんです
ですから この完璧になる必要はないんですけど
だからといって完璧なバカになったら困るでしょ
完璧な人間になる必要もないし
まあ完璧なバカになる必要もないし
できるだけ  ほぼ間違わないように
ほぼ間違わないぐらい
もうできるだけもうたくさん正しい判断できたようできるような人生でよろしいと思います
なんでそういうことをしますか？で
この決断の問題は 悟ったお釈迦様にしたっても問題でしたからね
お釈迦様の人生のいろいろエピソードを見ると
やっぱりお釈迦様もいろいろ決断の場合はまあ問題あったなと思います
見えるところありますからね
それをお釈迦様は隠してないんです
かっこ悪いと 嘘をついてついて
もう自分が神みたいな感じで
もうもう完全者で何一つ間違うことをしないんだとかね
ということはしてないんです
お釈迦様にもう仏教の中っていうのは結構いろいろ遊びやら面白いこともありますしね
ですから この仏教というのは自由な宗教だから
こういう疑問が起きたんです
皆様方はこのダイバダッタという人をご存知でしょうね
あのダイバダッタとパーリ日本語で言いますけど
この名前はデーヴァダッタなんです
このデーヴァダッタというデーヴァダッタという人が
お釈迦様の在家の時 結婚なさっていましたから
そのお妃の弟なんですね
義理の兄弟みたいなっていうんですかね
その場合は で その人は他の人々と一緒に出家したんです
でも出家する前からもうあまりお釈迦様のことは好きではなかったんです
在家で家にいた時でも
どうせまあお釈迦様は在家にいた時でも
なかなか人にはもう比べられない
もうかなわないすごい人間でしたし
もう立場もすごかったし
まあ家にいた時も みんなシッダールタ王子の方ばっかり見て
もう彼が我々をなんとか救ってくれる偉大なる人だということはずっとあったんですね
そうすると 大体同じクラスの他の人々には全然全然立場がないんだから
これあまりね ちょっとどこかで心に何かしこりが残っちゃうでしょうし
それでも自分のお姉ちゃんもね
捨てちゃって出て行っちゃったんだから
もうさらにもう腹が立ってしまったんですよ
いくらなんでも自分の兄弟だからね
そちらの方がもう可愛いと思うのは普通でしょうしね
それはまあ 一応お釈迦様は知らないわけじゃないんです
で 何のこともなく まあいいですよと出家させたんですね
出家したっても あの立場が消えませんね
かわいそうに ライバルでしたけど
一旦お釈迦様のと出家したったら
もう弟子でしょうに もうお釈迦様は偉大なる存在で
一番偉い方で もうそれ乗り越えることはできないんです
考えてみたら なんかもっともっと深い穴に落ちたような感じなんです
小さな穴に落ちていた人が
お釈迦さん出家したんだから
もう関係ないと これから私が偉いんだと
家で頑張った方がよかったのに
一旦出家したところで
もっと深い穴に落ちてしまったような感じなんですね
その人にとっては それから見たら
他のお坊さん方はもっと偉い弟子たちがいっぱいいて
お釈迦様から一番弟子
二番弟子とかいろんなもうたくさんいて
彼がただもう一人の弟子だけ
何万人も弟子たちの中で
だから考えたのは何でしょうかというと
まあお釈迦様を潰して自分がもう偉くなるんだと
この社会のグループの中で
それ企んだんですね そういうことを企んで
お釈迦様をやっぱり殺そうとね
まあ二 三回 三回かな 頑張って
ちゃったんですけど その三回の失敗で終わったんですね
そこで一番大きな罪 お釈迦様は仏教教団というものは作り
じわじわでできて上がった
出来上がったし 出家者がね
サンガっていうものをみんな仲良く修行して悟り開きなさいということで
もう大変な素晴らしいインド社会にとってはモデルになるすごい素晴らしい社会を作ってあったんですね
だから このサンガの集団は人類にはこの上ないモデルだと
模範だと だから あなた方はすごい気をつけて生活しなさいと
どんなことがあっても
お互いに喧嘩したり 別れたり
やり合ったりしてはいけませんと
何かちょっと問題 もうたくさんの人々だから
いろいろ異論ができたりしますけど
その場合はちゃんとした年上の人に
インテリの人に聞いて
話を調べて 正しい決断
判決をして 和を守って生活しなさいと
一番悪いのは この和を破ることだと
個人個人でお坊さんたちがいろいろ間違いするかもしれませんだけど
間違い自分がしたところで
自分が間違いだとわからないんだから判断ミスだから
その時 お釈迦様おっしゃっているのは
すごいインテリのお坊さんたちがいるんだから
そのお坊さんたちにお願いして
法によってどういうことが正しいかと聞いてもらいなさいと
判決を自分で出すんじゃなくて
虫と同じようなやり方
捕まって我々人間に見えるんだからバカだと
だったら見える人がその虫を捕まえて外に出せばいいんです
ですから そのインテリの年上のお坊さんたちに判断していただいて
そこを決めなやりなさい
それで OK やと喧嘩する必要はないんだと
あって すごくお釈迦様は厳密にこの和を守って
この世界をね サンガという世界
この人類に模範として
人類にモデルとして まあずっと
いて欲しかったんです
いるっていうことは この次から次へと出家する人々も
あの決まりを守ってモデルとしている
ですから 人類どんな時代の人々にも
まあこういう立派なモデルがあるんだから
それを見て我々の生き方を直せばいいということで役に立つんですね
で それでこの大仏だって何をしたんですかということ
あの和を破ったんですね
噂と 和を破ったらサンガは 2つに分けるんです
ダイブダットのグループとブッダのグループ
お釈迦様はそれだけはやるなと
自分を殺そうしたことに何も言わなかったんです
何も言わなかったんです
一言葉も あれには一応言ったんですね
いい加減それだけはやめなさい
それは罪の中で一番大きな罪ですよ
これ 人類に対して罪だから
人類に対して人類を裏切る
裏切ることだから お釈迦様から見れば
なぜならば そのサンガの和をなければ
人類に信理する方法がなくなっちゃうんです
みんなライフスペースに騙されちゃうんです
そういうふうな人間というのはいくらでもいるんだから
テーゼス論を語る だからサンガの存在っていうのは
人類のためにある存在であって
そこを破っちゃったらね
それはもう人類に対する裏切りであって
それ以上罪がないんです
罪のリストの中で そこで罪のリストの中で一番重い罪を大仏だと起こしちゃったんです
それでサンガの和を破って
我々は別なグループを作ろうということは皆様にはできない
サンガではありませんだから
例えば 日本人も分けて分けて別々グループ作ろうとしても
私にはできません なぜか
どうしよう 日本人じゃないんだから
ですからサンガがその中の人々が
我々はこの人々と一緒に行動したくないと
別に行動するんだということで破る
破ることだから だいぶだってにも
この和を破るために この一番大きな罪を起こすためにも資格が必要なんです
その資格はサンガの一員であることなんですね
それは誰が許可したかというと
お釈迦様が許可しちゃったんですね
だからお釈迦様は最初からもうこの人はね
もう小さい時から私に対してものすごいライバル意識で
もう ばっかりしてきたんですよと
あんた入ったら迷惑だからね
やめなさいという言葉を最初から言ったならば
あの大きな罪はデーヴァダッタには起こすことできなくなっちゃうんですね
それで後でまあ冗談でこういった話があるんです
デーヴァダッタがこの分裂罪を犯したのはお釈迦様のせいではないかと
お釈迦様は出家拒否しちゃったならば
デーヴァダッタはその分裂罪を犯さないでしょうし
今デーヴァダッタがアジビ地獄に落ちて
ずっと苦労しているんです
だから それお釈迦様はもう最初から何とかしたならばね
あの人あれほど苦しむないでしょうと
というまあ冗談の話があるんだけど
まあ話はまあお暇つぶ作ってるんだけど
まあそれは一応お釈迦様の判断の問題には関係ないわけでもないんですね
まあお釈迦様の時 そう誰ももう恐れ多くてそんな質問したことはないんだけども
後の人々はそうやって質問作っちゃうんですね
真面目に作ってるんで
その質問 私は冗談で言ったんだけど
仏典では あの あの この前もある勉強会で私はある本を読んでみてくださいと
ミリンダ王の本 日本訳あります
その中にもその問題あります
ブッダがブッダには全部状況を見えているんだからね
全部状況判断できる方がなんでデーヴァダッタを出家されたんですかと
出家させたんだから 彼が分裂罪を犯しちゃうんではないか
今アジビ地獄で苦しんでいるんではないかと
それはお釈迦様の判断ミスではないか
と それにまあ お釈迦様に聞いたことがないんだけど
まあそれにナーガラジュナというお坊様ではなくて
ナーガセーナというお坊様が答えるんですね
いえ それはブッダの判断ミスではありませんと
まあ本来悪い人だから
出家したってもしなくたって悪いことをしちゃうんだと
ですから 一旦サンガに入れて
いろいろ戒律で束縛させておけば
犯す罪が少なくなるんだと
言ったっても一番大きい罪を犯しているんだけどね
だからそれほど立派な答えにはなりませんだけどね
それはなんかあまりいい答えにならないなとわかったナーガセーナ長老がまた次の答えを言うんですね
それでもデーヴァダッタは真面目に修行したんだと
罪を犯しちゃったんだけど
戒律を犯したりとか まあそこ悪いことをしたわけじゃないんですね
それはまあ一応無理でしょうし
不可能でしょうし ああいう社会では真面目に修行したんではないかと
僅かながらでも瞑想もしたんではないかと
死にかけた瞬間で やっぱりお釈迦様に逆らって逆らって
自分がすごい悪いことをしたんだと
自分が間違ったんだと思って
やっぱり最後の瞬間で
やっぱりブッダは偉大なる存在で
ブッダに帰依した方が私にはこんな不幸にならないでしょうということで心変えて亡くなったんだと
それで将来彼も悟るんだと
はい だからお釈迦様はそれを助けてあげたんだと
というふうに答えているんですね
まあ私から見れば やっぱりそれもお釈迦様に一つの判断
どうすればよろしいかということはね
その場合 お釈迦様から見れば
もしブッダがあんた出家するなよと言ったら
一人の人を追い出したことになります
それで万人に真理を当てはめますよと
これは真理だから どんな人にも関係なく真理だよと
性別も聞かない もう国民
民衆 民衆 どんな民族かも聞かない
お釈迦様は人間であるならば
これはみんなに同じ教えだよということで
選ばれてる人間とか そういう概念何もない
それぐらい科学的に教えているところで
デーヴァダッタだけダメって言えないでしょうに
だから真理だから たとえ大仏さんであろうとも
修行すれば悟れます そういうことだから
出家を許可しなくちゃいけないんです
でも この人は出家したらまた何かやりだすということもあります
だからどうしましょうかね
やっぱりお釈迦様は出家許可することに
それでも出家を許可しますということになったんです
それは決して判断ミスではありません
あっきり見ると それもお釈迦様の判断ミスではありません
結果が悪くても判断ミスではありません
なぜならば それはもう最良の決断だから
その人を追い出すより
一人の人もお釈迦様は追い出しませんだから
一旦場を与えてあげる
一応 そういうことだから
まあそういう判断になってしまっちゃうんですね
またまあそうやって いろいろ
どうするべきかっていうね
問題に出会ったと 例えばお釈迦様は悟って
あまりにも真理は難しいということを気づいてことに気づいて
これは人間の言葉では語れないんだと
人間にとっては ただご飯食べて
子供作って 喧嘩して 家族と一緒にもう苦しんで死ぬことはもう精一杯なんですね
それしか頭にないんです
大きな何かにチャレンジしようとかね
そんな暇がないんで それよりは牛の乳を搾った方がいいと
で まあそれぐらいの人生ですよ
昔も今も ですから このこんな真理のことなんか言ったっても意味がないと
もう決めるでしょ 語れませんと
それも判断 決断でしょうに
でもある梵天が来て あんた頑張ってみないの？という話でしょうね
結局は 最初からもうわかるくはないと
諦めるんじゃなくて 人々はみんな馬鹿じゃないんだと
みんなもうもう家族のために乳を搾ることやら
畑に行って芋を掘ることやら
それしか能がないと思ったっても
みんなそうでもないんだと
もっとより高い次元の
より大きなものにチャレンジしたいという気持ちの人々もいるんでしょうと
世の中で だから頑張ってみないんですかと聞いたら
なんかお釈迦様考えて
そういえば人間というのはそういうものだと
みんな馬鹿っていうわけでもないんだと
やっぱり頑張ってみますと
また判断変えるでしょう
それを悟ったお釈迦様でしょ
ですから 私たちはもう完璧になろうと努力しなくてもいいんです
そうやってこのお釈迦様
負けたケースっていうのはもういくつかあります
逆にお釈迦様は自分の智慧っていうのは
もうどんな人間の智慧にももう比べることできないということを言っているし
それぐらい智慧があるんだったら
判断ミス起こさないはずなんですけど
でも人間と一緒に行動すると
まあいろいろ起きるんです
でもう一つ この有名な話で事実ですよ
一番古いところに記録しているんだからね
このダールシーリアスというある邪教の違う宗教の人が来て
で ものすごい真面目な人なんです
自分が阿羅漢だと悟っているんだと勘違いしていたんですね
長い間 でもある人が あなたはもう全然修行の方法も何もわからなくて
自分勝手に出家みたいなことをやって
出家遊びしていたっても
これはしっかりした方法を知らないと悟るということはありえないんだと
ちゃんと悟っている人がいるんだよと
行ってみたらどうですかと
話を聞いた途端 びっくりして
あ そういえば 自分が自分勝手に悟っていると思っているだけではないかと
やっぱりいるんだったら教えてもらわなくちゃいけないなと
そこをその日で 彼がもう旅に出て
ずっとこのもう南の方にいた人でしょうと思いますけど
ずっと歩いて歩いて歩いて歩いて歩いて歩いて
で 何日間も歩いたでしょうね
おそらく何ヶ月かでしょう
それは分かりませんだけどね
歩いてお釈迦様が住んでいる最上のところに入っちゃったんですね
で 入ってお手上げ そこに行ってみたら
みんなにもお釈迦様 ブッダがどこにいるんですか？とかね
ほとんどお坊さんがいない
ご先中 それは今はもう会うことはできません
もう托鉢に出ているんだと
どこへ どこへ出かけたんですかと
ちょっと待ちなさいよと
お釈迦様はたか座ってちゃんと戻りますと
戻ったらみんなに説法するし
その時はいくらでも話を聞きますと
質問もできますと そんな待っていられませんと
どこへ行ったんですかと
道を聞いて この人を追っていくんですね
ものすごい落ち着きない人間なんですよ
長い旅だからね もうちょっと休んで
お坊さんたちからちょっとご飯でももらって食べて
大体お坊さんたちはそういう人々に結構面倒を見てあげるんですよ
方法を聞くために遠くから来たならば
まあ休ましてあげて 病気だったらそれなりになんとか治療でもお薬でもあげて
お腹が空いているんだったらご飯でもあげて
寝るところでも用意してあげたりとか
その面倒を見てあげるんです
で それなのにもうもう慌て者で
もうもう追っていったんです
追っていったら やっぱり街で見つかるんですね
お釈迦様が 家から家へ托鉢に出てくる
そしたらもうあんたですかとね
ブッダというのは まあ私ですけど
じゃあ私に悟り方法を教えてくださいと
いきなり 私にも悟りたいんだから教えてください
って言ったら まあ皆さんも知っている通りに
この瞑想法っていうのはね
そんな簡単に軽々しく教えられないでしょうね
これすっごいもう心理の世界だから
ひながく すっごくゆっくりとゆっくりと教えてあげないと
お釈迦様はね 今はちょっともう托鉢してるんだからね
もう後でいいですよ 言ったら
いいいい もうもう待てませんだからね
今教えてくださいと 言ったら
今説法する時間ではありませんよと 2回目に断るんです
食事の後教えますから
で この人も３回目に言うんですね
食事なんかいつでもできるでしょうに
今日できないこと 明日でもできるでしょうにと
でも人は死ぬということはどうですかと
じゃあ今日死なないで明日死にますって
そんなできませんでしょうにと
死ぬことはいつ来るかわからないんだと
生きれれば食べることはいつでもできるんだよと
だからあなたはご飯食べることよりは
私に悟りの道を教えることはなんて優先だよと
お釈迦様から教えてもらおうという人の態度なんですね
でも 正しいことを誰が探っているんですか？その場合は
あの外道の人なんです
彼が言ったことはその通りだから
人はいつ死ぬかということは決まっていないし
ご飯食べることはいつでも計画立てるでしょうに ６
時に食べるか ７時に食べるか ８
時に食べるかと 死ぬことは何もできませんでしょうに
時間決めてないんだから
いつ訪れるかわからないでしょうに
それは事実なんです その事実をお釈迦様に言ったら
それはその通りですと
３回目断らなかったんです
それはまあその通りです
じゃあ聞きなさい と悟りの方法を教えたんです
ほんのちょっとの二 三行なんですけど
で その瞬間にその人悟るんです
それはまあお釈迦様だからね
やっぱりものすごい厳密に真理の世界
悟りの心っていうのはどんな心かと
こんな心だよと 言ったらわかった
その わかって そのまま
はい もう結構わかりましたと
私は出家をお願いしますと言ったら
じゃあこんな変な服でできませんだからね
彼がこの木の皮を腰に巻いていたんですね
だからサンガの世界というのは大変
この文化的な世界で変なことは認めませんだからね
すごい行儀よくいないと
私はそうじゃないんだけど
で ですから必要な衣とか持ってきてくださいと
で そこで彼がそういうものを探しに行ったんだけど
死んじゃったんです 亡くなったんです
だからまあそれもお釈迦様はわかっていたかもしれませんし
この人寿命も終わりでしょうと
ですから このそれで一番短いから
だから一番早く悟ったっていうのはその人なんです
瞬時に悟ってしまったという
お釈迦様は結構苦労しましたからね
道を探すために ですから
こので そのストーリーはストーリーで別なことなんですけど
その場合でもやっぱりお釈迦様と何の仏教の話も知らない人のやりとりで
お釈迦様はすごく何のことなく負けるでしょ
ブッダの判断だからしませんよとかね
定説ですよとは言わないんです
そういうことだから 偉い人にしたっても判断ミス起こす起こる可能性あります
それで全然偉くない ごく普通の人がまともなことを言うと
あ なるほど あんた言うことまともですねと言って
それをちゃんと受け入れるぐらいの人間になってないと
なんだあんた言うこと誰が聞くんですか？というのはもうけしからんな生き方です
本当の人っていうのは
そういう いくら偉大な偉大なる人物であろうか
そこら辺の人がまともなことを言ったら
自分言うことよりもまともだったら
なんのことなく なるほど
その通りですねと 認めてそれを実行する
ブッダのすごいところはそういうところなんです
お釈迦様のものすごい
もう怖いほど立派なところはそういうところ
あれほど知恵あったのに
まあ普通の誰かが言ったことはその通りだったら
まあその通り だからそうやってお釈迦様さえ
いくつかいろんなところで自分がした判断が後で取り消しするんです
それはそのケースなんですね
相手がもっとまともに
まともらしいことを言うと
あ そう じゃあそうしますということで
ある日 お釈迦様が すごい長い旅に出たんですね
出たところで ものすごく歩いて歩いて歩いて
で いつかこの道二つに分かれるところに来たんです
だからもうそこでアナンド尊者が
まあお釈迦様のお世話するんだから
もう心配ですね まあ自分の責任でもありますから
お釈迦様にちゃんとご飯
一日一回だけですからね
それなんとかもうもらうことできますか？とかね
もう体でも洗いたくなったら水でもありますかないかとかね
そういうことをちょっとありますから
お釈迦様よりアナンド尊者の方はちょっと責任が多いんです
お釈迦様はずっと歩くだけですから
そこでアナンド尊者がちょっと待って
お釈迦様にお釈迦様 道が 2つありますけど
この道はすごく長いんだと
1ヶ月間大きく長くなる可能性あります
でも 町を通っているんだと
町やら村やら ですから
まあご飯とかね 飲み水とか
夜ちょっと休むところとかは困ることはないんだと
で もう一つ この道がすごい短いんだと
でも森と山を通っていかなくちゃいけないんだと
人はいません 一人 時々
まあ山の隠れてる泥棒とかね
まあそういう恐ろしい人々もいるんだと
でも 1週間ぐらいでも行けますよと
もしかすると一日かもしれませんしね
どうなさいますか？と
でお釈迦様にも判断迫るんですね
そうじゃあ私はブッダだから
じゃあこっちで そんな態度取らないんですよ
ああ そうですねと言って
みんなを見て 他の人々の調子と
見たら まあこの短い道のチャレンジできそうなんですね
ちょっと怖いとこはあるんだけど
それほど弱い人々はいないんですね
すごい年取ってる人とかね
そこを見て で 短い道で行きましょうと
早い道で行きましょうと
そこを決めたところで
この経典にもう一人の阿羅漢がいて
かなり恵まれているんです
運がいいんです その阿羅漢の名前はシーベリと言うんですけどね
だからどこにいても困ることはない
なんとなくなんかわからないんだけど
もう恵まれているんです
だからお釈迦様 まあこういうもうなんて言いますか
ラッキーボーイというかね
まあ普通の言葉で言えばね
こういうまあ随分過ぎてる人もいるんだから
まあ何もならないでしょうと
シーベリもいるし あの人いるところだったらもう多分
困らなくてもいいんだと
ですから 山を歩いていきましょうと言って
その道を選んだんですね
それで無事に行ったんですけどね
まあちゃんと食事ももらえましたみたいし
あのツユリ阿羅漢の徳で
ブッダの徳ではなくて
で そういうことで やっぱりそういう場合もお釈迦様はじゃあ私がブッダだからこう決めますということではなくて
ちょっと状況を見て みんなの様子を見て
まあ山歩きにチャレンジできそうということがわかったところで
じゃあ山歩きで行きましょうということになるんでしょうし
だから完璧に判断できるんだったらね
そんないろいろ調べる必要ないでしょうに
まあ  そういうふうに まあそんなに簡単に正しく我々に
判断できないかもしれませんだけど
いつでも我々はどうするべきかで
いつでも心を広こせて
この狭い目で物事を見ないで
来るだけ大きい目で物事を見て生きていなくちゃいけない
判断のやり方とか まあ後で後半で説明しますけど
最初は我々の性格の問題
もっと言いたかったんですね
ですから 人を間違ったんだからといって人を馬鹿にするんじゃないんですよ
それ自体はバカバカらしいし
恐ろしいんですね 人は間違って
それは一向に構わないんです
その人はわざと腐ってるリンゴを選んでるわけじゃないんです
その人の能力のギリギリのところでその判断しているんです
それだけ理解すると 我々にはこの判断から起こる問題っていうのはものすほとんど解決できます
判断ミスから起こる問題っていうのは
親子関係であろうか 学校の関係だろう
会社の関係で 人間関係において
我々は相手が間違って悪いんだと思っているんだから
相手が間違いましたゆえに悪いと思って
その人をもう何て言いますか
攻撃するでしょうに 潰そうとするでしょう
そうすると答えが出てこないんです
特にそれはもう簡単なことじゃない
なぜかというと 今日バス停で待っていると
スピーカー 2つ棒につけて二人が歩いているんです
あの神様を信じなさいと
神様はとても優しい方ですと
あなた方をすべての人間を救ってあげますと
神の怒りに触れるなと
神の怒りに触れたら あなた方はどうしますかと
というと 私はバス停で待っている中で
ずっと後ろを向いて こいつには一言葉言わなくちゃあかんと
いくらなんでも 私も人を馬鹿にするな
なかれと言いたかったんだけど
見たらあれ あれ持ってる人が外人なんですね
なんとかもう変なもうヨーロッパのね
見る限りにもアホもいいところでね
ああ もう話通じないと
英語でやりとりやらなくちゃいけないでしょうし
英語がわかるかどうかもわからないし
もう一人 生まれつき脳細胞を取り出しちゃったような日本の若い男の子がいたんですね
この二人であ まあ教えないということで
悔しいんだけど まあバスが来たし
乗っていっちゃってきましたけどね
で わしは何を聞きたかったんだ？神様が怒るんですかね
そんなに はいと言わなくちゃいけないでしょ
ああ 怖い すごい怖い もし頭がちょっとでもね
あったならば 自分たちが言っている言葉が無意味だと
無意味なことで人を騙そうとしているのではないかと
無意味ということさえも自分たちで気づいていないんですね
だから私にとって怒りが生まれたんじゃなくて
なんとなく面白くなってきてね
まあちょっとからかっちゃえば
その人々もなんとなく考えるだろうと
だから別に宗教をやめるんではなくて
もっとマチな言葉でも
言うだろうという気持ちが起きたんだけど
やっぱりその状況はそれほどいい状況じゃない
もし私も忙しいしね もう遅れているし
だからそういうやりとりする時でもなかったんだから
タイミングが悪かったんです
だからやらなかった で
そういうことを そういう世界で我々は生きているんだから
非で人が間違ったら悪いと
そちらも考えてそういうこと
神を信仰しなかったら悪い
故に神が怒る 人の判断が間違ったんだから怒るべきだということを私はずっと言ってきたんです
虫が窓から出て行こう出て行こうとするのに
もう開いてるのに そちら見つからない
故に虫を潰すべきですかね
こいつはバカだから潰してやると
そうする人間何者ですかね
例えば鳥でもずっと部屋に入ったところで
部屋に入ったら驚いちゃって
そういう経験一回私にありましたか
太陽村にいた時はね 茨城県の
窓を開けちゃって もうそれ床の上に横になって
一人一人だからね 誰もいないしでいると
いきなり鳥一羽が飛んで出ちゃったんですね
窓を開けてあったんだから
だからどこを見やっても藪ばっかしだから
鳥にとって窓を通ったっても藪しか見えませんし
入ったところで小さな部屋の中
ものすごく怖くなっちゃって
逃げていこうと思って
いきなりガラスにぶつかるんですね
だから開けたところで来たんだから
そちらから帰れと言えばいいんだけどね
あんた帰ったと 来たところから帰りなさいよと
そう帰らないんですね
窓にポンポンとぶつかる
あっ これ大変だと この子は怪我するかもしれませんと思ったんだけど
これ結構可愛いんですよ
あまり見たことがない種類なんですね
それで私がそんなことじゃなくて
窓を閉めて 鳥を捕まってよく見て観察して
で 捕まったところですごく怖くなっちゃう鳥がね
なんか死ぬ恐れがありますからね
怖くなったら まあまあ怖くなるなよとね
ちょっと撫でたらものすごく落ち着いちゃったし
それでもうすごい安静にしたんだからね
それで見て 結構顔綺麗な可愛いでしたしね
それで窓を開けて逃がしてあげたんです
ですから 例えば部屋にそうやって鳥が入り込んじゃったところで
自分が入った道あるのに
逃げようとすると 窓から逃げようと鳥を潰しちゃうんだと
バカだからというと それはいかに間違っているかとお分かりになりますか？故に神が怒ると言ったら
彼らが何を言っているかと人間に
真理のメッセージかと
神を信頼信仰しなきゃ神の怒りに触れるよと
それだけでも彼らが語っているのは真理でもありませんし
人間の道でもありません
彼らが真理わかってない
人間の心はわかってない
生命の心もわかってないってことなんです
ただ 自分中心に物事を考えてるだけです
ですから そういう人間にはならないでください
大きな大きな人間になっていただきたいんです
それから 身分でどのように判断するべきかということは
いくらか説明いたします
どうも ちょっとこれから聞いていたします
ありがとうございます
え あの一応 どのように判断すればよろしいかというところを話しさせていただきます
あの  だからどんな判断で困ってるんですかね
大体は人間っていうのは
そこをわからないとなかなか喋りにくいんです
なぜならば ずっといろんなことを判断して生きているんだから
判断の正しいやり方を知りたいなというと
判断に困っているところではないと
ところで こういうことで困っているんだとね
ですから すごく具体的にならないと話が話しづらいのです
まだまだ具体的な例をないんだから
いくらか勝手に考えています
で 判断しづらい あるいは
正しいかどうかわからないと
あるいは自分が正しい判断をしたいんだと
そういう悩みがあるということは
選択いくつかあって どっちにすればいいかとわからない時なんです
判断に悩む場合はね ですから
私はただ哲学的だけのポイントを考えて
もし人間が判断に悩んでいるんだと
判断ミスを恐れているんだというならば
それはおそらく選択いくつかあって
どちらにしようかなと悩んでいるところではないか
選択ないと問題ないんです
一つ例 水はすごい怖い人がいる
もう悪いことに その人は川のそば
家を建てている あるいは隣はもう学校のプールがあるんだ
窓を開けたらそちらにプールだと
水は嫌いだからね 怖いだから全然興味もない
嫌だなという気持ちでいるんです
そこである日は自分の家は火事になる
玄関の方は全部前からずっと火事になって
もうものすごい火が出ていて
逃げるところは窓しかないんです
そこで前に自分が嫌いな川かプールがあるでしょ
だから逃げないね だって私は水が嫌いだから玄関から逃げますよと
そうしないです その場合はもう選択ないんだから
その場合はプールであろうが川であろうが
そちらに飛び込む 泳げるかないかも気にしないんです
だから判断に困ってるなと思ったら
もう選択いくつかあって
どっちどっちにしようかなという時なんです
それでも答え簡単です
判断いくつかあるんだったら
どちらににしなさいよと
その人の能力から見れば
どっちにしようかなということだから
どちらにしたっても長所
短所いろいろあるし だったらどちらにしたっても同じことなんです
どちらにしても そういうことで判断に困るし
全然ないんです  それでも少々判断についてちょっと理解してほしい
で まず我々は何か判断する前にという決断する前に
まず考えてほしいのは
何のため 誰のためということ
誰のために今決断しようとするかと
そうすると 2 3つ見えます
自分のために あるいは誰か他人のために
あるいはみんなのために
私のために判断決断する
あるいはあなたのために私が判断決断する
あるいは私たちのために私が判断決断するという 3つのステップなんですね
そこをよく勉強して頭に入れておいてほしいんです
いつでもこのおおざっぱで生きているんじゃなくて
我々は判断に迫られるときは
その判断自体は私のための判断か
あるいは全く他人のための判断かと
あるいは我々みんなのための判断かと
その 3つしかないんです
で  1番目 私のための判断だと
私のための判断だったら
簡単な答えは勝手にしなさいと
自分のためのことだから
それぐらいわからないと
ですから 自分のための判断だったら軽々く
やるしか方法ないんです
だって私がどうやって
その人はうどん好きかラーメン好きかと決めて決めれますかね
あなたにはもうたぬきうどんが一番美味しいんですよ
多分私は判断してあげますかね
それは それは自分のことだからね
だから自分のことぐらいは自分で判断しなくちゃいけないんですね
そんなに困る必要はないんです
だから困っているのは
この問題 このポイント
この決断する この出来事が確かに誰のためかということをはっきりすることだけ必要なんです
そこは大体人間の中ではっきりしていないんですね
子供のためだという 言ってはいるんだけど
調べてみると自分のためになってしまうことも発見できるでしょ
私はみんなのために みんなの取り合う
調べてみると 自分のためにやってるんです
政治家とかね 宗教家とかね
世界の救済 救済してあげようと思っている
思っている この天から降りてくる人々やらね
よく見ると自分のためにやってるんです
でも 書く本も聞く 言う説法も
すべて人類のために 民のためになんです
自分が犠牲になって頑張ってるんだと
でもお金くれと ですから
世の中でそこはまあすごい
もう無知の世界だから
それぐらいの明確な判断がないんです
だから 今日の説法はどのテーマでいこうかなと思ったら
ちょうどバス停で私にもうテーマをもう提供してもらったんだからね
神の怒りに触れたらあなたはどうしますか？と
それで あ これやと 寸切りも全部もうこの内容はそこで決めちゃったんです
そうやってなんか私たちのために
まあまあ それはまあ 一応一般的な世の中で正規の宗教だからね
まあそんなに問題にする必要ないんだけど
一応このカルトとかね
まあカルトの方がもっと強烈ですから
もう神 自分が降りてきたんですね
天国から そういうように喋るでしょうね
私はもう釈迦になったっていうことですと偉そうに言うんだから
よくよく見ると 釈迦にもお金は要りませんでした
イエス様にもお金は要りませんでしたし
釈迦にしたっても イエス様にしたっても
結局迷惑でしたからね
教えてあげること自体はね
あなた方のことだから
自分かってやればどうですかという気持ちでやったのに
うるさいんだから教えてあげるぞっていうぐらいで
だからお金くれとはなかったんです
ご飯くれとかね それ代わりにわがまま言ったら怒るんです
わがままで言うんですかと
あなたのためにやっているのにと
それぐらい態度で お釈迦様もイエス様も二人とも言ったのに
これ生まれ変わったところ
ぐらい違うんですね  三百万円というのは神が決めたんだと
私は知りません そこまで言ったりとかね
ですから 私たち人類なる問題は
自分たちがいろいろ判断したりするんだけど
その判断は本当に誰のためかと明確にしてほしい
三つしかないんだから
自分のため きれいさっぱり他人のため
あるいは私たちのため
それははっきりしないのは
例えば家族の場合はね
いえ 子供のため 子供のためと言っても
家族だから おそらくあれは私たちのためかもしれませんでしょうし
いえ 会社のため 会社のためと言っても本当かなと
そんなにも会社のために仕事したければ
別な会社にでも行って
無料で無報酬で仕事してあげればいいでしょうに
そうしないでしょうし
ですから はっきりとこれは誰のためかと
と決めてもらわないとおかしくなっちゃうんです
だからカルト団体に入ったのは子供のためやと
ああ やっぱりしょうがないね
子供のために母親はそんなことをするのはね
まあわかります 気持ちと
そんなこと言うなよ 調べてほしいんです
その母親が本当に子供のために入ったかと
あるいは旦那に対して不満があって入ったかと
どちらかありますよ 調べてみる
ですから お釈迦様の智慧から言うならば
判断は完璧にしなくてもいいんでしょ
前も言ったんだから それじゃなくて
気を付けてほしいのは
この判断 この判決の決断は誰のためですか？って
この三つ 私のため 全く他人のため
あるいは私たちのためだと
それで私のためになった場合は
自分のことだからね 自分がいつお手洗いに行くかということは私に決めてくださいと言っていいわけじゃないでしょうに
自分がトイレに行きたければ
その時行けばいいし 自分のことだから
それぐらい単純に考えてください
だから自分のことぐらい自分で判断できるぐらい知識能力は必要なんです
それぐらいのことはいくらかはあるとも思います
でも問題があります 虫の例で見ると
虫は自分のために外へ出たいんですね
私たちのためじゃないんだからね
自分のために外へ出たいんです
間違って入ったんだから
でも出られないんですね
窓ガラスからは それで虫に言ったって
あなたのことだから勝手にしなさいと言ったっても
虫にできないでしょ 見えなくなる
その場合は 虫は人間様のお手を借りなくちゃいけないんです
その同じこと私たちにも起きる
判決は自分のためにやらなくちゃいけないんだけど
どうも見えない 自分にも
虫になってしまっちゃって
窓ガラスを通してしか空は見えないんです
でも 窓ガラスを通ってはいけないし
私たちも時々そういうことにぶつかっちゃうんです
判決ははっきりと自分のためであるにも関わらず
どうすればいいかとわからないと
その時もやっぱり選択策はいくつかあるということ
よく一つ具体的な例で言うならば
このまあ 小学校なんか終わってくるとね
子供たちはそれからどうしようかなとすごく悩んだりするでしょ
あれ すっごく悩むんでしょうにね
だから本人たちわかってますよ
次に自分のことだから
親のことじゃないんだと
次にどうすればいいかと
どこに入ればいいかと
すごく真剣悩む その場合は子供は虫なんですね
外へは出たいんだけど
わからない その時はどうすればいいんですかと
その場合は 相手のその人が自分のための判断なんで
その人はやっぱりはっきりと相談に乗ってもらわないと他の人に
ですから 決断の場合は
自分のための決断であろうとも見えない時があります
その時はちゃんと他人に相談に乗ってもらう
それは必要なんです そういうこと必要だからこそ
私たちは皆様方に鋭い判断能力を最初から持ちなさいと言っているんです
なぜかというと そうでないと人が死んじゃっても
それは医者が死んだと言うんだけど
死んでないんだと 私は 2週間かけてもう力入れたらちゃんと元気になりますよと
治してあげますよということに行くんです
それをテレビで言うんですね
やっぱり父は殺したのに
その娘が やっぱり日本では定説は通用しませんということでしょうと
偉そうに 定説って言葉自体ももうバカバカらしい
定説って何ですかね よく言うでしょ
だからもう判断能力何もない人間ではないんですよ
人間は肉付いてるだけで
それで人にカウンセリング受けちゃったら
あんなものになってしまっちゃうんですね
結局殺されてしまっちゃうんです
だから我々は必ずしも人に相談しなくちゃいけないんです
自分のことについてで
どうすればいいかと その時は誰に聞いても誰にでもいいわけじゃないんです
誰でもいいわけじゃないんです
そこのところは自分の判断能力ちゃんとあって
私はこの人に聞くんだと
という人を選ぶ能力は自分でないと
だから言っただけで言わないで
だから神の怒りに触れるなと
触れたらあなたはどうします？大変だ
触れてはあかんという馬鹿がバカバカらしい判断ではなくて
やっぱり信じなきゃ大変だと
神は怒ったら誰も助けてくれないんだとかね
神が怒るんですかと 私が失敗しちゃったら
そうです それは怖いと
と言って逃げればいいんです
だから そちらにあるこのヘリックス
見つかるぐらい自分に能力
判断が必要なんですね
それだったら今の社会にある問題ってほとんどね
一つの新興宗教に騙されたら次の新興宗教を探すという
そんなまあ笑われちゃうんでしょうね
世界の人間から それはなくなると思いますけどね
ですから 例えば今 子供の問題言ったんだから
子供のケース言ったんだから
だから子供だったらハッキリ知ってるでしょうに
自分のことを今まで誰が見てきたんですかと
今まで自分を誰が育ててきたんですかと
ですから 一緒に隣に座っている子供に相談するんじゃなくて
友達に その場合は学校の先生と仲良く時間かけて話してみたりとか
あるいは自分の親とか親子結構仲良く喋ってみたりとか
そういう風にいろいろ違う目で問題を見ていただくんです
先生の目で見ていただく
母親の目で見ていただく
父親の目で見ていただく
それで自分 自分で判断する
そうやってちゃんと相談に乗るということは必要なことなんです
ですから お釈迦様が言うのは
いつでも智慧のある人々と付き合いなさいと
人間が幸せになりたければ
賢くて鋭くて 物事をよく見る
自分と違う目で物事を見る人々とかね
そういう人々と仲良くしないと
喧嘩するんじゃなくて
人間 誰と喧嘩するかというと
一番大事な人と喧嘩するんです
へんどころな宗教なんかを教える人とは全然喧嘩しようともしない
反乱しようともしない
質問しようともしない
はいはい わかりました
両手挙げて 親がなんか言ったらまあ攻撃して当たっていくこと
学校の先生何か言ったら殺すでしょうに
先生を だからそれは仏教的ではないんです
ですから 人間には本当に正しい判断
決断をしながら生きていければ
やっぱりいつでもまあ何かあったら相談に乗ってくれる人
相談に乗ってもらう人が必要なんです
だからお釈迦様のことを言っても
人の話聞きましたから
女性に出家認める時も
お釈迦様の真理から見れば
別に性別ないんだから
生命に語っている真理だから
そんな女性出家っていうのは当たり前でしょうに
でも だからといって私はもう真理を知ってるんだから
決めるそうと 女性にはみんなに平等に出家認めるんだと
そんなことはしなかったんです
そんな自分勝手にいきなり判断するんじゃなくて
よくよく環境状況を判断して
判断して 状況の情報データをね
いろいろ取ったところで
まあ条件付きで女性にもまあ出家認めるんですね
そこで一番後でお釈迦様が言うんです
なんでそんなにまあ女性たちに八戒律や数多いんです
で なんでちょっと余分に戒律つけたりとかね
それちょっと不公平ではないかなと
言ったら その時お釈迦様は本当のことを言うんですね
それは取り消しちゃったら
世の中の人はどう言いますかと
私に対して お釈迦様にとってはその余分な八戒っていうのは別に対して意味あるわけじゃないんです
やっぱり世の中の人々の考え方を配慮して
インド社会だからね 女性を差別する社会だから
その文化の中でも生きていられないんだから
だから外から見る人に
やっぱり女性は別扱いしているんだというふうに勘違いできるように作ったんです
別扱いしてないんですけど
だからもう日本のある女性から手紙があって
すごく怒って テーラワーダ仏教にさえて
なんで女性をそんなにお釈迦様はもう悪いのに
なんで差別しているんですかと
私たちに 現代日本の女性にとっては理解できませんと
ただ 私はものすごい厳しく答えたんですね
あんた方には平等も何もないんだと
いまだにあなた方は原始的で差別されているんだと
余計なことを言うなという気持ちで書いたんで
そういう風に書いてなかったんだけど
あの世界は自由ですよと
あんた方は決める手段でやる必要大きなお世話です
それは その国の女性たちがね
自由を欲しければ自分たちで頑張るでしょうと
日本の女性には何の自由もないんだと
それでも最後のもう決まり文句として
日本でもいまだに政治家でもアメリカでもね
女がなったことがありますかと
仕事をしたら 子供産んだら仕事辞めるでしょうと
あれ差別じゃないかと
あんた悪口言って そういう国にはそんなことあるかと
調べてくださいという風に言ったんだけど
やっぱりそこで違う目で見ると
そんなに怒る必要ではないことなんですけど
やっぱり誤解するようにちょっとセットしているんです
誤解というのは まあ女性はちょっと別に扱っているんだと
平等に扱ってないんだと
でも中に入ってみたら全くわけが違うんです
女性は平等に扱っているだけではなくて
女性に対していちいち文句を言う権利もないんです
男性に だから我々には女性を出家させる権利さえないんです
例えば こちらの女性 誰かがね
私しか見たことがないんだから
私は出家したいんだけど
出家させてくれと言ったらできません
お釈迦様は権利を与えてないんです
それぐらい自由なんです
女性の方は 女性が出家したければ
女性のお坊さんのところに行ってお願いしなくちゃいけないんです
男はいちいちいじることはしません
だから 中に入ってみたら
これすごい平等というか
ものすごいみんな独立させているんです
他の点では 誰が説法するべきかというと
これはちゃんと法を理解している人が説法するべきですよ
男か女か決めてないんです
もし女の方がすごい頭が良くて
賢くて 説法するどいんだったら
彼女が説法して男のお坊さんたちが手を合わせて聞いているんです
だからそういう世界なんですけど
外から見て まあテーラワーダ仏教で女性を差別しているんだとよく言うんだけど
ミャンマーでも民主主義運動をやっているのは女性なんですけど
自分の国でも国をちゃんと治めて頑張っているのは女性なんですけど
日本やらアメリカやらどうですかと
ヨーロッパとか女性に何か立場がありますかと
もし皇太子様の子供が女だったらどうですかと
だからそういうことで私たちにいちいち文句を言ったら
ちょっと ちょっときついことになります
判断のことで でお釈迦様さえも人の意見も
一応調べてみるんです
人の意見だから 決して正しいというか
ブッダから見ればみんな悟ってないんだから
意見間違ってるんです
間違ってるんだけど やっぱり決断するときはそこもチェックしてみる
ですから なんで私たちは
私たちも たとえ自分のことにでも
私が好きだからやるんだということじゃなくて
私はこういうことをやりたいんだけど
あんたどう思いますかと
聞いてみるのはいいんです
私は留学したいんだけど
どう思いますか？だから
いい加減な人に聞いたらいい加減な答えになるんだから
誰に聞くべきかということは
そこでまた自分で決めなくちゃいけないんですね
本当に真面目に人のことを心配すると
この人が相談するでしょ
あれ かなりストレスかかるんです
こういうことですから
どうしましょうかと言ったら
平気であんたこうしなさいと
真面目な人言わないんですよ
あの問題は本当に自分の問題のように計算してみて
結論出すんだから その人も結構苦しいんですよ
その場合 例えば子供の問題にしたっても
子供の次の将来の道を決める場合は
おと おと 大人の人々は平気で
あんたこういう風にこと勉強しなさいよとか
そんないい加減に無責任に言えないでしょうに
ですから その場合は子供と同じく相談してあげる
教師であろうか 親であろうか
結構厳しいんですよね
ですから それぐらい自分のことを心配してくれる
自分のことを理解してくれる
それから よくよく能力ある知識人といつでも付き合いなさいというのは仏教の決まり
周りのそういう人が調べてでも付き合いなさい
それぐらいのことを世の中でやるんだったらね
こんなに世の中は苦労がないでしょう
まとめの人の話を聞かない
精神的な病気だったら
その人の話を聞く 私の耳元で神様が言葉を言ってくれると言ったら
平気でそれを信じる 親の話は聞かない
あるなんとか変な宗教団体にあるテレビに出るあるタレントの女の人が入っちゃって
そこでお父さんのかなりの知識人でそういう話を言うときで
お父さんはめげないで
もう頑張って頑張って
ありったけの研究したりして
とにかくその自分の娘をその宗教団体からまあ脱退させてもらったんだからね
すごいと思いますね 父親はすごい知識人で
まあ日本でもインテリ
大変有名なインテリの人でしたし
ただ単にやるなやるなってことでもなくて
自分が入っているところは間違っていると
それはこの教え違うんだと自分も研究して
教えてやって 教えてあげて
それはインチキだ 脱退しなさい
それでもうちゃんと脱退できたし
それからもう真面目に仕事をして
まあある程度結婚もしましたけど
で だから私はあれはすごい素晴らしいケースだと思いますね
まあ素晴らしい父親として見ると
いい加減ではなくて 本気で心配して
だったら本人も娘よりも苦労しなくちゃいけないんですね
娘はただ単にもうアホだから信仰しただけなんですけど
父親はそうじゃなくて
向こう側から脅す脅しがあるわ
いろんなことあるわ そういう何にもめげないで
とにかく研究し続けたんです
だから一番苦労したのは誰かというと
父親の方なんです  そういうことだから
そんな父親いれば まあもう最高に幸せなんですけど
まあ時々ない場合もあるんだけど
とにかくいい相談相手が人間には必要なんです
そうでないと どんな落とし穴に落ちるかわからないんです
我々は虫と同じだと思った方が一番安全なんです
部屋に入った虫とは大した変わりがないんだと
そこで それ自分の判断の場合は
まあもう一つ軽い例なんですけど
自分が好きだからといって
いろんな服やらね いろんなアクセサリーやらね
それは私の好みだとみんな偉そうに言って着て着ているでしょ
あれもちょっとどうかなと思いますけどね
本当はみんなわかってないんです
自分がすっごいかっこいい服を着て
ブランドのお品物をいっぱい体にあちこちつけちゃっているのは
あれ自分のためですか？とはっきり理解してほしいんです
例えばブランドのカバンでないと自分はお腹でも痛くなるんですかね
下痢になるとか あるいは膝が痛くて歩く歩けなくなくなるとか
そんなことも何もないでしょうに
なんであのブランドを探すんですかと
だからこの それは簡単な例なんですね
服を着るとこの自分に見えませんよ
例えばすごい底がね 20 センチの靴に乗ったところで
あの歩き方美しいかないか自分に見えますかね
ですから そういう単純なことでも
例えばちょっとしたネックレスなんか
チェーンなんかね 首につけてもどうですかと誰かに聞いても
別にそれはいいと思いますね
そうするともっともっと美しく自分を見せることはできると思いますけどね
そこでその場合は 例えば男の人に聞いたっても意味がないんですね
このネックレスどうですか？と言わないで
本当のことは男は まあそれ怖いんだからね
まあ相手は ですから まあその場合は
例えば自分の他の人生のこと
他のことを心配していると
いろいろトラブルがあると言ったら
男の人に言ったらもうすぐ助けてくれる可能性ありますね
何か問題あると心配事があるんだと
言ったら でもこのネックレスは似合いますか？と言ったら言わないでしょうね
おそらく あるいは自分をなんとなくストーカーやってやってるんだよと
自分を知っている誰かに言ったら
その人が待ち伏せストーカーやってやってるってぶん殴る可能性もありますよ
ぶん殴ってその人を守ってあげると
それでもその人のネックレス似合いますか？と言ったら言わない
だからなぜそういう例を言いますかというと
自分が誰に相談するべきかということは自分で決めなくちゃいけないんですね
大体はね  あんまりいつでもそうじゃなくて
例えば自分着てる服はね
まあかっこいいかないかとか
自分の母親にでも聞いてみればね
つまり母親にとっては
自分の娘が綺麗であればあるほど気持ちいいんです
だから本当のことを言う
父親に聞いたっても どんなもんでも父親にとってはもう可愛い
娘は可愛いんです で 言わない場合もあります
まあ実は言う時も言いますけど
やっぱりそうやって自分がこのケースバイケースで誰に聞くべきかと
うん まあそれぐらい自分の判断の世界
そこら辺で終わりましょう
次に他人の判断なんですけど
他人のこと 他人の だからこの判断は他人のためにしなくちゃいけない
全く自分のためではないと
はっきりした場合はどうしますか
まあ大体皆様そこまで経験ないでしょうと思いますけどね
他人のために判断した経験というのはほとんどないかもしれませんだけどね
うーん まあそれも言ってみれば悲しいことなんですけどね
会社と家族しか他の生き方ないんだから
全部自分のためだからね
たまに他人のために決めなくちゃいけない時もあります
素晴らしい政治家の場合はね
こういうおそくもういろいろ腐ってる政治家ではなくて
本気の政治家が政治やってると
その場合はその人の判断
決断 すべて国のためになるんですね
自分のためではなくて
自分の名前を売れるために
次の選挙に勝つために
あるいはもっと儲かるためにやる判断ではないんだからね
そういう人々もまれにはいるんです
だから 皆様の人生の中でも
純粋に他人のために何か判断してあげるということがあれば
その分 思います  例えば隣の家の奥さんが自分のその奥さんの子供のことで自分に相談したとする
それでそれで何かしてあげても
判断してあげても それは自分のためではないでしょうね
まるっきりその隣の奥さんの子供のために
その場合はどうしましょうかと
その場合は本当にものすごい真剣
真面目に きれいな慈しみで
なんとかして その子の問題を解決してあげたいんです
という風な すごい真剣にやらなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうたくさんいろいろあります
その場合は親切でいいし
じゃあ子供はお母さんと喧嘩するんだったら
なんとかこちらに来るように言ってくださいと
こちらでご飯食べたってもいいんだと
私はおばあちゃんだからあまり喧嘩しないでしょうと
そうすると あの子はもう弱くてね
まあなんとか話し合ってくれると
私はそれでいますよと
そうやってもうやってあげて
自分は全く他人の子なのなのに
自分の家で自分のこと同じく
まあいろいろ親切にしてあげたら
これすごい献身的な行為でしょうね
それでその人は必ずしも助かるし
自分がすごくいいことをしたことになるし
そこでいつでもわがままということは出てきて
もうなんとか遠慮して
なんかこの まあ何かスティックで触るような感じで
もうその問題を扱ったりするんだから
まあろくな相談者にもならないですね
時々もうきつい判断しなくちゃいけない時もありますね
まあ例えばもう例えば立派な政治家なんかいると仮定しちゃうと
もう単なる想像の話だけかもしれませんだけど
たとえ国民が一時的に混乱したっても
嫌だと言ったっても 国にとってこれはしか道がないとわかったらきつく判断する
で 国民はあなたは次の選挙でむちゃくちゃもう投票しないで
もう任せてうちに帰しちゃいますよって
じゃあやってくださいと
それで私はやりますと
これはと それぐらいでも強力的にやらなくちゃいけないんですね
なぜならば これは自分が他人のためにする判断だから
それは自分には問題見えているはずなんです
人のことだから大体見えているんです
だから他人の判断はそういう風にするんですね
そこで我々の判断 まあ会社のためとかね
とか家のためとか言うんだけど
それは嘘であって それはすべて我々のためなんですね
ですから その場合は私たちのための判断だと思って判断するんです
その場合は両方を得しなくちゃいけないんです
会社損して私は得するということはダメで
私が損して会社だけ得すると
それもダメです 例えば母親と子供の間の場合は
母親は子供のため 子供のためといって自分が損するのはこれは間違いで
子供も母親が言うんだから私はこういうことをやるんだと言って
自分が犠牲者になるのも
それも間違いで それは理解していないんですね
母親に責められて何か学問を決めると
それは正しくないんです
それで子供に聞けば なんであんたはもう母親がずっとこれをやりたがってるんだからね
まあ母親のためにやってあげると
自分がすごい親孝行しているつもりなんですけど
結局自分の人生は不幸になっちゃうでしょうし
だからその場合 家族 会社
そういうところの判断は
自分がなんか聖者になっちゃって
純粋に他人のためにやってるんだというあの犠牲をやめた方がいいんです
子供に怒る場合は あるいは半分自分のためであること
理解して そうするといい結果が出てくるんです
どういうことかというと
母親は犠牲になる必要ないんです
子供のためにと言って
それで犠牲が起きてくるんです
子供もやっぱり両親に言うことだからといって
自分を犠牲にする必要はないので
これは我々の問題であると
だから母親も喜んで 子供も喜ばなくちゃいけない
会社も喜んで 社員も喜ばなくちゃいけない
そういうふうな方向へ行動を変えなくてはならないんですね
ですから 正しい判決をする場合は
その判決は誰のため？というポイントは
一番大事なことで 世の中は忘れていること
それ理解してもらわないと立派な生き方はできないんです
で 次にこの判断するとき
私たちはなぜ失敗するかと全部説明しましたけど
これは理解の問題ですよ
だからまあしょうがない
かわいそうやということを前言ったんだけど
やっぱり人間にそれでも何とかすることはあります
この視野がすごく広くするために
あるいは見方が狭くなることあるんで
その狭くなるそのものを
邪魔物を取り除けばいいんです
見方が狭くなっちゃう
その邪魔者を取り除き
除いてほしい その 4つあります
それは まあ覚えている方々がいると思いますけど
この 4つ覚えておいてください
大体判断する場合の基準として
お釈迦様はこれしか教えていないんです
この 4つ チャンダドーサ
バエ バエ モーハという 4つ
この 4つがあると判断は間違っているんだと
わかりやすい だからこの 4つはあってはならない
その 4つが心に入る 4
つの一つでも心に入っちゃったら
まあすごく狭くなっちゃうんですね
窓ガラスしか見えなくなっちゃうんです
だから人間の正しい判断できなくて判断ミスするのは必ずしもこの 4つからなんです
これ勉強して これないようにしましょう
で  1番目 チャンダというんですね
チャンダっていうのは
まあすごくこのいろんな方向で意味言えますけど
それはわかりやすく言えば欲かもしれません
でもお釈迦様は欲という言葉は使ってない
まあ好みという訳はいいかもしれません
好み この好みで判断してはいけません
間違います それは自分が好きなんですね
最初から だからもう判断の余地がないんです
正しい判断する余地がないんです
で あの日本でことわざありますね
美人が得する得するよってなんとかありますね
ことわざではないんだけど
一般的に言うでしょ え？美人は得するんだというふうな聞こえたことはありますけどね
ん？それ違うかもね え？え？あ
それも違う それ全部ことわざだから
そうじゃなくて まあ一般的にもうみんなもう普通に喋る時は美人が得ですねとかという場合あります
それことわざじゃない
まあただ普通の日本語で言います
あれ あちらにこのこの心理入ってるんです
あの言葉に 例えば 私が人に何かやってほしいんだけど
頼んでもやってくれない
そうすると すごい美人の女の子にあんた行ってちょっとお願いしましょうと行ったら
何のことなくやってあげると
そこで男の人がなんかわがまま言ったら怒られる
そこですごい綺麗な女の子がわがままを言うと
ああそうああそうと言って全部やってあげると
だから それゆえに この世の中で美人はいつでも得するんだと
ということなんです そちらにこのチャンダの問題がちゃんと働いています
だからそこはそれほどそれほど軽々しいものでもなくて
すごい厳密なことですけど
例えば犯罪を起こした人がいるとする
その人はすごいもうかっこいい人だとする
まだ若くてすごいかっこいいと
そうすると みんなちょっと手を緩めるんです
判決の場合 ですから この恐ろしいことをする時も
結構美男とかね 若い人とか雇っちゃうといくらでもできそうになるんです
だからこのセールスの場合も
あのどかのおじいさんに
もう会社でいたっても
あんたあまりろくに仕事もできないんだから
もういろいろ家に家に行ってね
まあ頑張ってみなさいと言っても
一つも売れないんですよ
それで会社が考えるのは
かなり若い男の人々を結構決まってる服を着させてね
ちゃんとブランドのスーツを着させて
すごいいいネクタイをつけちゃって
もうピンポンとか言うと結構売れるんです
で そうやって人間にこういう弱みがあるんですよ
顔を見てすぐ心が変わっちゃうんですね
あれ気をつけた方がいいんです
たとえ見たら本当に可愛くて可愛くてと思っても
やったことは別に判断するべきなんです
あんたは可愛いんだから許してあげますとかね
それはいけません ですから
我々の心の中でいつでもチャンダというものがあるんです
あるんだからこそ 判断ミスを起こすんです
このいろんな人々がね
なんで人間でそこまでバカなことを言うんですかと
私もいろいろ悪口言うんだけど
裏に まあこの人々 このチャンダにやられている
精神的にもうもう頭がもう全部壊されているということもまああるんです
見えますけどね あまりにも欲望になってしまって
いろいろたくさんご利益欲しくてね
損する人とかいるでしょうね
甘い話にすぐ乗ってしまうとかね
甘い言葉にすぐ騙されるとかね
それはチャンダなんですね
なんでこのコマーシャルにいつでも可愛い
有名な人気のある連中ばっかり出てくるんですかね
あれ コマーシャルのストーリーも全然関係ないんですね
やっぱりあの人の美しさに
やられちゃうんですよ
品物を頭に焼き付けちゃうんです
買ったりする まあそれは別にまあどうったことないところなんですけど
皆様は毎日にその経験がありますから
そこから我々大事な判断をする時でも
その間違いは起こしますということだけは気をつけてほしい
ですから 判断する場合はあくまでもクールで
相手がいくら美人であろうか
もう何でしたっけ？東京都にいるあの女の人って何て言いますか？舞妓さんであろうか
気にしないこと で その仏教のことを何も知らないある方が
そちらの家族で大変ないろいろトラブル
問題があって この財産のことでもうかなり苦しんで苦しんで
どれほど苦しんでいるんだというと
この全部財産をとにかくまとめて寄付したいんだとと思っているぐらいで
それでも兄弟いろいろいるんだから
まあ親もいるんだだからそんなこと勝手にできない
一人が全部自分だけもらいたい
親がそれあまり好きじゃない理由は
もらっても他の兄弟は賛成するんだからもらってもいいんだけど
この姑さんがちょっと
娘息子をもう騙してるんだと
もう何も料理もしないんだ
ということで 親として腹が立ってるんですね
親に来たんだったらそれなりにしなさい
それぐらいのこと 自分が別に来たんで
それでとにかく私にでも何か言ってくれませんかということで
家族の一応話し合って集めたんです
その一番攻撃している男性の方も
彼も結構いろいろ会社やっていて偉い人でしたけどね
それその奥さんなんです
で 奥さんも来る前にこの相談してくださいと頼んだ人が私に先にこう言うんです
あの人は元宝塚の結構有名な女優でしたと
だからものすごいこの自分の美根と言うんですか
美しさで すぐもうみんなやられちゃいますと
だからあなたも気をつけなさいと
最初に注意したんですね
その人は だから別に私はそんなことを気にしませんだけど
でもあの注意はしっかりとした注意なんです
決して変なことではないんです
それで見たら全くその通りで
まあ綺麗というと もう全部明るい
もう何のこのすごい笑顔だけで
もう歩き方やら座り方やら
まあ全部もう洗練されてあって
だからその人に向かって
あんたね しっかりこれ言えないでしょうね
なんでそんな態度とかね
旦那に対してとかね だから正しく判断する場合は
やっぱりすごくそこら辺気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
私はそんな簡単に見るのは難しいんだから
だからまあ私はそういうこと
まあ向こうはその武器で
頑張ったし 男性の方はいつでもまあ感情で喧嘩することで頑張ろうしましたし
もう私にも何とかしてくださいと頼んだ人も
自分の性格でやろうとしたし
私はもうどちらにも乗らないで
ちゃんと客観的に論理的に問題って数学的数字的に解決するような感じに全部持ってきたんで
じゃああなたの言い方
自分はどうですか？そちらは
あ そうですか それでこれでこうなって
これでこうなって それでどうすればいいんですかね
あなたの場合は そこでみんな自分自分持ってる武器を忘れちゃって
私が出した武器で戦争しなくちゃいけなくなったんですね
それは厳密に論理的なことだから
間違っている論理は負けると
まあまあ 全部解決しましたけど
何のこともなく だから
このチャンだということは
我々の判決を必ずもおかしくする
それ気をつけ 好みということですけど
これ大変なこと です どこを見ても人間の判断ミスなんか見ると
ものすごい人類に損する場合もあるでしょう
判断ちょっとした判断ミスで戦争を起こす場合もあるでしょう
ですから この政治家にお釈迦様よく言うことで
政治をやるならば 国民の人々を預けて治めをするならば
もうあなたはもうあくまでも人間だったらダメやと
こういうのはごく普通の人間の感情だから
この好みあるということはね
それは捨てて すごいクールな人間にならないと
正しい判断できません
2番目動作 これ好みの反対は何ですか？嫌なものでしょ
嫌ということですね 気に入らないと
それで判断してはいけません
これは怒りなんですね
時々家族の中でありますけど
時々この親にしたっても
気に入る子供 気に入らない子供いるんです
出ちゃうんですよ 例えば
ある子供が父親があんまり気に入らないと
そうすると その子は何やったってその子に怒っちゃうんですね
このタイでこの田舎から逃げてきた子供
バンコクでいて そこのプログラム一つNHKで流しちゃったんですね
そこで家出したある男の子
こう言うんですね お父さんがアル中でいつでも酒飲んでるんだと
そこでいつでも私に怒るんだと
私は何したってお父さんが怒るんだと
だからどうすればいいかさっぱりわからなくなっちゃった
で 逃げた 家出します だから
あの子供のことを考えちゃうと可哀想でしょう
子供は悪い子じゃないんです
子供の頭にはわからなくなっちゃったんですね
父親に愛されるようにしたいんです
父親にああ いい子だよと言われるように
父親が喜ぶように自分で生活をしたいんだけど
向こう側は何やっても怒るんだから
そこであの子供は不幸になってしまったんでしょ
それでどこで間違いかというと
やっぱり父親でしょ 父親も好みじゃないでしょう
でしたでしょうね そこまで私はわかりませんだけどね
そこまでは推測なんですけど
父親にはあまり好ましというか
まあ好みじゃないんですね
だからちょっとしたことで怒ったりする
そういうことだから 判断する場合は
自分の怒り 憎しみ 決して持っていってはいけません
あの 裁判の世界でもよく使うような感じで
日本人の感情とかね あんないろんなことを計算したりして判決をきつくするとかね
あるいは軽くするとか
私は上々じゃないと思いますけどもね
判決は判決でちゃんと法にのっとって
罪にふさわしい判決を出さなくちゃいけないんです
日本人の感情は運とかね
あんなことはどうでもいいんです
判決の場合 感情なんか当てにならんでしょう
全部間違ってるでしょうに
ほんのちょっと悪いことしちゃったら
その人は永久的な悪人だと永遠に恨む人間だから
誰でも間違いを起こしちゃうし
後で後悔したりして また立ち直ろうともする場合もあるし
それでもそれを見ようとしない
あんた昔こんなことやったんだからと
ということでね  とその人を責めたりするで
そういう人間の感情だから
そこを配慮してものすごい重く判決するとか
それは意味がないんですね
人気の歌手が何か間違いを起こしたら
あんたはもう若者うるぎりましたから
厳しい判決とか そんなことはもうものすごい間違いと私は思いますけどね
法律だからちゃんと数学的にやってほしい
どれぐらい罪を犯したかと
それには法律ではこれぐらいの罰で決まってるんだけど
ですから この怒りの感情もブッダは否定しているんですね
怒ったんだからといって
もう気に入らないんだからといって判断しては決していけません
例えば 自分は本当に怒っている人がいて
自分が嫌なんで その人のこと
でも その人について何か判断しなくちゃいけないことになったとする
その場合は綺麗にはこの人を私個人的には嫌って
それを置いといて この問題は誰が間違っているかとちゃんと見なくちゃいけないんです
で  3段目 映え映えっていうのは脅威
恐怖ということですね
怖いということ 逆に言えば脅し
脅しがあるとみんなもう決めてしまっちゃうんですね
気にしてはいけません
今言えるのは 思い出すのは法華経なんですね
大変ありがたく信仰している経典ですけど
脅しですね あれは読んでみると
人を脅すんです ヨーロッパの宗教と全く同じなんですね
私を信じなきゃ この経典を侮辱したらもう地獄ですよと
いい加減にしなさい それだったら私だったらそんなもんなん
なんで脅すんですか？なぜ脅すかというと
人は怖くなっちゃうんですね
地獄に落ちるんだと 先妻さん亡くなっちゃうんだと
成仏できなくなっちゃうんだと
ということで怖くなっちゃって
じゃあ信じます じゃあ認めます
そんなことは だから人間は怖いという感情はあるんです
だから私こそ神様ですよという人々がいるでしょう
それで聖飢魔IIやと
もう後はないんだと 私言うことを聞かなかったらもう全部終わりやと
天国も行けませんと言ったら
みんな怖くなっちゃって
そちらに行っちゃうでしょ
そうやって人が決めれば
やっぱりその宗教を決めましょうと
宗教に決めましょうと
まあ例で言いますけど
皆様の家に来る あのなんとかと
という宗教団体 脅ししか持ってないんですね
聖飢魔IIになったら
もうこの宗教を信じる人しか救われませんと
そうすると怖くなる アホな人だったら怖くなる
まあ私は勝手じゃったら勝手にしなさいと言いますけどね
私はある人がもう来て
そんなあまりも 他の家に行くんだだからね
次にこの奥さん二人が来て
次の人家に行ってね 次の人も騙しちゃうんだから
じゃあここでも なんとかしますということで
これ人のことを考えて
別に私は知ってる人 他人向こうのこと知りませんだけど
私はやっぱりちょっと興味ありますからって話しましょうと
４時間ぐらい喋りました
そこでは向こうももう家ありますからね
家に帰らなくちゃいけない
もう隣の家に行けません
で どうやって話続けたんで
向こうは延々ともう聖書にいろいろラベルを貼って持ってきて
これを開けて そこを行だけ読む
次の行だけ読む だから頭悪いってことははっきりわかるでしょうに
そこで私も読んでいるんだから
そちらにないものを聞く
この場合はどうしますかと
それでわからなくなっちゃって
もう調べるわ 調べるわ
聖書ってそんな簡単に調べて見つからないんです
で 時々まあちょっと待って
この問題にはこう言ってます
私は開けて見せるんで
ここら辺にありますから
だから向こうはどういう態度を取ったっても
どっちもわからない状態にとにかく持っていって
最後に言うのはこの脅しで
で こうやって聖飢魔Ⅱ分けてもう大変で
もうみんなもう地獄に落ちるんだと
本当に言ってました そんなことを
で だから持ってきて こっちは言ってないんだ
そんなこと でって私が
いえいえ ちょっと待って
ここら辺にはいくらかありますけどと見せてあげて
そこでですね 問題はと
私は最後に読んで そこであなた方の宗教を信仰している人々はどれぐらいいますかと
まあはっきり はっきりした数わかる
まあこれぐらいいますよ
数いくらか言うんですね
それは地球上の全人口から何パーセントぐらいですかと
そうすると あなた方の神様がこの聖飢魔Ⅱで
このこのグループだけでしょ
生き延びるのは みんな一緒に死ぬでしょ
他の人々 あなた方の他の親戚もみんなね
だから寂しいんだと あなた方は
私は知ってる人と一緒に死ぬことに決めましたと
聖飢魔Ⅱで そんな自分だけ一人で誰もいない世界でね
面白くないんだと それに答えがないんだから
もうもう帰りましたけど
あと あまりも長い時間喋ったんだから
紅茶でもいいかどうかですかと
飲まなかったんですけどね
ですから これ人がこの弱みというかね
脅しに恐怖感を持ってるんだから
そこをいじってそこをいじって人をバカにしようと
我々には判断ミスさせようと
だからオウムに入ったのも判断ミスでしょうに
他の宗教団体に入るのも判断ミスでしょうに
伝統的に家がクリスト教で自分がクリスト教のそれは判断ミスではないんだけど
そうではなくて すべて判断ミスでしょうに
政治家はもう偉そうに判断ミスやってるでしょうに
喋りながらちょっとしたことで
そういうこの恐怖ということ
だから脅しにはもう乗らないこと
決して  もう一種類の脅しありますけどね
借金取り立てとかね まあそれはちょっと脅すかもしれませんだけど
その時は逃げるしかないんですけどね
まあそれは別に変な脅しじゃないでしょ
お金返してくれということだから
まあ法律的にはそれでちゃんと禁じられているんですけど
まあそれはまあ実際の脅しだから
目の前の脅しだからね
目の前に殴られるかもしれませんだからね
自分の子供が学校に途中で誘拐する可能性もありますから
それは具体的な怖いことだから
具体的に怖いことからは逃げるということは当たり前でしょうに
地震があったらそこに行く人がいないでしょうに
火事があったらそこに行く人がいないでしょうに
洪水だと思ったらそちらに行こうと思う人がいないでしょうに
そういうのは実際に人間にある怖いこと
それは脅しではありません
そういうものから逃げるんです
台風が来るんだと もう高波が出るんだったら
船は全部さっさっと持ってきて
もうちゃんと結んで逃げなくちゃいけないんで
津波が来るんだと言ったら
家に海海岸に行って津波見てやるぞと
そんなことやる人はいませんだからね
ですから 脅しって言ったっても
そこらへん区別してください
この区別判断はいつでも必要なんです
実際に自分の身に危険が出てくる時は逃げてください
とにかく そうでないと判断の世界っていうのは別な世界だから
その時は一切脅しは使わないこと
虚仮教を信じるか 般若心経を信じるかといったら
脅しあるところは捨てると
何のこともなくポイと捨てればいいんです
脅しあること自体でも間違ってるんです
そこで脅しなし これこそ偉大なる徳があるんだよと言って欲を煽り立てるんだったら
まあ気をつけた方がいいんです
落とし穴あると そうやってしっかりした人間になればいいでしょうに
知識人になれば ちゃんとした頭のいい人間なら
それはお釈迦様の道なんですね
4番目 もう無知ですね
わからない わからないんだからやるんだと
だからなんか問題わからないと決断してはいけないんです
例えば 子供は学校登校を拒否しているんだと
全然わからないんだと言うと
何ですか？と わからないんだったら
いろんなことをやらない方がいいんです
わからないのにも関わらず
ああしなさい こうしなさいとかね
あっち引っ張ってこっち引っ張ったりとかね
わからないんだったら自分に判断能力がないということだから
それはもう手を挙げた方がいいんで
私はわかりません できませんと
何も そうすると誰か分かる人をやってくるでしょう
そこで政治的な判断をしたとしても
経済世界の判断にしたっても
わからないのにもいろいろ対策するでしょう
こういうことをしたら
本当に経済成長するかしないかはっきりしてないにもやっちゃうと
例えばみんなに 1万円配っちゃうとか
もう配っちゃったでしょうにね
商品券なんとかといって
あれで経済成長しました？しましたかどうか分かりませんだけど
私は全く部屋の中の世界しかしないんだから
まあ一応話だけは聞いてるんだけど
あの話はテレビでニュースとして聞いた瞬間で
まあバカのいいところやと思っちゃったんだけどね
はっきりしたデータ持ってなかったのにも関わらず
こんなことをしたら国が経済的に活発になるんだという歴史的なデータもなかったし
よくやること お金を配るという事実
具体的なことっていうのは
もう食べるものがなくて大変困っていると
そういう人々もみんな同じ人間だから
生きる権利あるんだから
まあ公にお金であろうが何であろうが取ってあげて
命を助けてあげると という場合は意味があるんでしょうに
これでもブランドのカバン持ってあちこち買い物に来てる人々に
またまた 1万円 はい どうぞと
それでわかりませんだけどね
まあそういう単純な計算でね
あれで考えたら 我々これぐらいお金を出すんだから
そのお金はまた返って業者に戻ってきて
業者が回転するだと お金
たまらん どこかの業者に例えば百万年余分に入ったんだからって
何にもないんでしょうに
そんなことで  ですから
わからない時は判断しない方がいいんですね
それでわからないと我々は判断を間違う時もあります
そこで  その 4つだけ気をつけてください
その 4つは今日はあんまり難しい説明しなかったんだけど
ものすごい問題なんです
ですから 皆様 今日からまあいくらでも人は判断ミスを犯すでしょ
その判断ミスを犯す場合は
腹が立つことではなくて
客観的に勉強してみてください
その人はなんで失敗したんですかと
そうすると チャンでかどうしたか
場合か盲目か このどっちかでしょうとわかるんです
それで自分の勉強になるんです
例えば 怒りに怒った時は言うこと無茶苦茶でしょ
そんな時 判断なんかしてみてください
子供が悪いことなんかしたところで
自分がいきなりカッとなっちゃうでしょうね
その時 怒りだからもう判断はしませんと
すぐやめた方がいいんですね
私は怒ったんだから あっち行ってくださいと
例えば 子供が何か問題があって
母親父親に聞いたところ
すぐ怒ったと 怒ってそれから偉そうに説教したりと
それ間違いなんですね
怒ったならば あ まあちょっと待って
私はものすごくこの話を聞いてすごい怒っちゃったんだからね
じゃあ中止と一旦 一旦話は中止
あんた部屋に帰って お父さんが怒りがなくなった時
話してみますと そうすると正しい判断できるんです
ですから かすかにでも怒りが出たら
まあもうやめた方がいい
あるいはわからない時はもうやめた方がいい
この 4つがあると判断しないで中止してください
それから  4つが心に生まれないように気をつけてください
それから 他人が判断ミスする時も
自分が判断ミスする時でも
この 4つのどちらかに引っかかっていることは確かなんです
それは後でチェックして勉強してください
別に判断間違ったんだからと後悔したり
悩んだりする必要ないんです
そんなことはどうせあるもんだから
それは悩むんじゃなくて
ちゃんと勉強してみる
なんで失敗したんですかと
この心の心理学的なところを反省会をやって
自分一人で勉強してみる
そうすると正しい判断になります
それから正しい生き方っていうのは
八正道の生き方なんですけどね
八正道の生き方ね 八正道の話はしていますから
そこら辺講演なんかテープなんか聞いて
八正道って何でしょうかと
その生き方はやってみてください
そちらにはいつでも正見というところから始まります
正しい意見 まず正しい意見を作らないと生きていられない
行動できない 正しい意見というのは
いろんな側面で問題を考えて
データをちゃんと取って
自動的に答えが出るんですよ
データ揃ったら 最初から判断つけてぶつかるのではなくてね
まあいろいろものを考えてみて
みてみて 見たところでちゃんと答えが出てくる
正しい意見で行動すればいいですね
それから 喋る言葉やら全て正しいことをやると
そういうのは八正道なんですね
八正道では喋るときも正しい言葉を喋ってくださいと
行動するときも正しい行動しなさいと
考える時でも くだらんことを考えないで
役に立ついいことを考えなさいという言葉ですから
そこは後で勉強してみてください
それから判断する場合はまた基準がいくつかありまして
そういうのは仏教でも厳密に決まっている
基準 4つありまして 自分が判断すると
これは自分のためになりますかと
それから他人のためになりますかと
それからみんなのためになりますか？それはいつでも聞かなくちゃいけない
今 私はこういう判断しようとする
でもそれは私のためになりますかと
やったところでとやる前に推測してみるんです
じゃあ他人のためになりますかと推測してみるんです
みんなのためになりますかと
そこでみんなのためになる
自分のためになる だったらそこは実行してみる
故に判断だってそれわからないんです
本当は ですから 一応それなりの判断なんですけど
それはまあいい結果になるんだと
だったら別にそれぐらいで十分です
完璧に判断するそうと思ったら
それ無理ですからね 我々にできるのはそこそこの判断なんです
ですから このそこそこの判断でもいいんでしょうし
でも結果だけは悪い結果出してはいけません
ですから 結果論で考える
子供に怒るのは悪いかもしれませんだけど
でも怒っちゃったらこいつは勉強するんだと
わかったら別にどうってことないんです
故に怒ること正しいわけじゃないんです
怒ることはそれでも間違いなんですけど
自分にとってはまあまあそれぐらいですよと
できるなのはそこそこ
だから完璧な判断できませんかもしれませんだけど
良い結果出せるようにと
たとえ自分が判断正しいと思っても
結果が悪いんだったらやめる
それ気をつけてほしい
それ最後の一言葉 どうしても生き方
それでも難しいというならば
お釈迦様が永遠的にこの人類の中でずっと続ける真理を教えてるんです
それは罪の話なんです
こういうことは悪いんだと
過去においても 現在においても
将来においても やってはいけないこと
嘘を言うこととかね 殺生することとかね
よく知らない行為をすることとか
考え方がおかしくなることとかね
そういうお釈迦様はやってはいけませんと思ったことは
どうにもならないと思うならば
それは厳密に守る いかなる理由があっても
私はやってはいけないことはやりませんと
例えば殺生だったらしませんと
嘘だったら言いませんと
いくら脅されたっても
いくら損されたら言いませんと
そうすると判断の問題はなくなっちゃうんですね
なぜならば 罪を犯さないんだから
綺麗に生きていられます
それをどうせ人間悪いことをしては必ず決していけませんだけど
正しい判断できれば悪いことはしませんよ
正しい判断が私にとってはちょっと無理だなと思うならば
だったらまあ悪いことはしませんと決めちゃえばいいんです
それだったら 大国に入った人々もあんなことはしませんでしょうに
いくら誰に言われたって悪いことだけはしませんと
そういうことで 最終的に判断どうしても無理と思う方々は
まあ罪は絶対起こしませんということで生き方は決めるんです
そういうことで大変ありがたーく生きていられると思います
長い時間お話ししましたけど
どうもありがとうございました